alors qu avec du scotch et attentes
mais quand la paix et uk ouais j'ai ma
meuf et ma gosse avec moi je te dis pas
la galère mais on peut pas tous faire
comme toi ça c'est sûr sérieux je fais
quoi très change de disque il sort tout
ce fric pourquoi tu m'agresses comme sa
cousine va falloir que ça change ici où
tu vas comme ça j'essaie de rentrer chez
moi c'est bon maintenant où je vais vous
pourrir la vie des personnes parlent à
ma mère si tu avais les moyens de
changer les choses
que ferait il y faut que tu paies comme
ça avec ton cruising down the street
hockey et c'était du lourd man vous
écouter les enfants terribles comme
donne ice cube easy et dr dre écoutez
bien parce que ce sont prada tu les gars
vous fait peur
votre voix est unique le monde doit
l'entendre
ils veulent du n de bonus on va leur
donner du ndé bonus
que le sommet de l'iceberg messieurs
qu'est ce qui se passe durant quelques
fois dans sa vie tu déconnes
tu prends pas ça donne
ses chansons font l'apologie des gangs
et de la drogue notre art est le reflet
de notre réalité
vous seriez pas trompés de rue ce sont
des artistes de rap c'est plein de quel
droit vous débarquer ici à glisser mes
clients parce que leur tête ne vous
reviennent pas te promets
que les choses vont changer
à partir de maintenant
je dois être honnête avec vous je
connais absolument rien au hip hop mais
je sais vous sortez du lot
je veux vivre comme un gangster c'est ça
tu es servi les que tu parle franchement
les gens pètent un câble
ce n'est pas le crimson blocks il s'agit
d'une menace du gouvernement
audrey y à quoi faut que je passe un
message si on continue qu'on va
conquérir le monde
les basques